all right hi everyone thanks yeah so
glad you're here
thanks so much for coming along I know
there's like a bunch of other talks that
you could have gone to so I'm excited
that you came to see mine frictionless
front-ends for back-end developers I
promise it'll be fun well I think it'll
be fun it'll be fun for me I don't know
if it'd be fun for you but hopefully it
is so just a couple of things about me
my name is Mandy I'm a front-end
developer I'm also a dev manager for a
news organization in Australia I speak
at a bunch of conferences in Australia
and overseas about the front end I like
to play with sensors and browser api's
and fonts and all sorts of stuff and I
also write a bunch of blog posts and
stuff about the front end as well so I
feel like I'm qualified to talk to you
about building front ends my talk is
pretty much things that I have taught
back-end developers that I have worked
with a large portion of this talk is
stuff that I've taught one specific
developer that I work well his name is
Jake actually he's presented at MDC
before and he has been my willing test
subject for about three years now very
importantly before we get into the talk
this is my dog jelly and this is
important because my demos use what I
call jello Epsom which is fake text
about my dog so when you see it you'll
know that I'm talking about him and not
about the food jello so you can imagine
this cute face as we go on you are
following on twitter i'm andy underscore
kerr i am wearing a bat mask in my
profile picture so it's super easy to
find if you have any questions things
that I haven't answered you can either
come and speak to me tomorrow or you can
message me on Twitter and I will happily
help you out so when I talk about the
front-end I am specifically referring to
HTML CSS and JavaScript for the purposes
of today because I only have an hour
we're only going to talk about HTML and
CSS
and the reason for that is because I
find back-end developers tend to pick up
JavaScript relatively easily in
comparison to HTML and CSS which I think
because the mental model around thinking
about HTML CSS is quite different to
JavaScript which is similar to other
programming languages people tend to
struggle a little bit with it so we're
going to focus on improving at the
presentation and UI layer of building
websites or web applications and I will
give you some little tips and tricks
that everyone can follow for design
purposes because the back-end developers
I know are always like I can't design I
don't know how to do that but you can
because design is just about patterns
and systems and we're developers and we
love patterns and systems so you can
absolutely do it so this is what we're
going to talk about whenever I've worked
with back-end developers and on teams
where they're heavily resourced with
back-end developers they typically will
rely on UI kits like bootstrap that is
totally fine I don't want anyone to feel
bad about using bootstrap however there
are some problems with using something
like bootstrap and the most obvious and
biggest problem with it is if you think
about how you build the rest of your
tech stack at the beginning of the
project you know the least about it so
you start small and you build on top of
it you add the things that you need as
you go a UI kit is the opposite of that
where you typically take the whole thing
all this stuff whack it in your project
maybe you need it maybe you don't then
when you want to change stuff you add
more stuff on top of that and then all
of a sudden you've got this really hard
to maintain unusable front-end and then
you're like the front-end sucks so hard
to use
well that's because you went around
about the wrong way so what we're going
to do is in the next 50 minutes we're
gonna build this page it's kind of like
a web page slash admin system featuring
a bunch of things we're going to use
under 200
of CSS it's going to have a bunch of
reusable styles that you can change the
content to do different layouts and as I
said before I'll teach you some design
tips along the way so hopefully you'll
get a bit of an understanding of the
different things that you can do on the
front end before we get into talking
about HTML and CSS I'm going to briefly
take a detour and talk about types
languages who here has used a type
language like typescript or something
great so most people this is going to
make it so much easier to explain so for
the few people that didn't put their
hands up a type language basically makes
use of static typing so we can assign a
type to our data it'll check the type at
compile time and if the value it
receives doesn't match the value that we
assigned it'll be like but you can't do
that doesn't work so for example we
might have an interface of dog named age
is fluffy
my dog is fluffy if I assigned a string
too is fluffy it would be like Bert you
can't do that I want a boolean
essentially we're being explicit about
the shape of our data
we're telling typescript what we expect
it to be and we do this to make
debugging reading writing and working
with our code a lot easier this is
essentially what we do when we write
HTML in HTML we specify whether we want
something to be a header a foot up a
link a video and image a caption whether
it should be bold or italic there are a
whole suite of elements you can use in
order to best represent your content and
we do this for similar reasons as to why
we use tax creams to make reading
working writing and debugging our code a
lot easier but in the case of HTML it's
not just for the developer it's also for
the technology that consumes your HTML
so for example the browser when the
browser hits a heading 2 or an image or
a video annoys what to do with those
because it knows what it is
the same thing applies to technology
like screen readers for accessibility
when a screen reader hits a button it's
able to tell the person using the
technology what to do with that button
that you can you can submit something
this also applies to other
text-to-speech technologies like Google
home Alexa Siri when they read HTML if
they know what the elements are they
know what to skip and they know what to
read out and what importance is
associated with the different content
along with this you have other
technology like reading modes in Safari
which will strip a bunch of stuff out
that it's that's not important and leave
you with just the important parts it can
only do this if you use HTML correctly
and the same thing applies for automated
testing if you use HTML the way that it
was intended automatic testing becomes a
lot easier now in pipe script there's
the concept of the any type when you
assign a type of any it means it can be
anything if you do this everywhere you
obviously lose the benefits of the
language you don't get the safety the
typescript provides so it kind of
becomes pointless because it can be
anything this is exactly the same if you
divs everywhere in HTML it's really
important that you actively choose the
correct HTML element because if you use
a div you're using a generic element and
if you use a generic element you get
generic output so at this point I'm not
going to go through all the HTML
elements that exist your developers you
can read specifications mdn great
website through there check it out but
there's a couple of things I want to
really point out make use of sectioning
elements they pretty much do what they
say section marks upper section article
marks up articles or blog posts or
things like that
now navigation aside a sidebar
they're going to do what you expect and
what these do is tell different
technologies what the most important
thing on the pages so for example if you
had an article element and a sidebar
element in a reading mode it would ditch
the sidebar and take just the article it
would also ditch the nav because that's
not important in a reading mode if you
don't have these it takes everything and
it all lunges together in unformatted
text and it's really hard to use
you should also define a clear structure
and hierarchy you can do this with
sectioning elements but you can also use
things like header and footer as well as
the headings which are h1 to h6 this is
so important everybody the headings are
numbered for a reason you should use
them in order so H 1 2 2 3 3 4 5 6 if
you go 6 1 2 4 3 that's the wrong order
and you mess everything up so make sure
you use the headings in that the number
audio order that's provided and most
importantly never choose an element
based on what it looks like in the
browser people do this with headings all
the time and I get the desire to do that
but the styles that are applied to
headings by default our suggestions not
rules and CSS is there to change it so
always pick an element based on how it
best represents the content and finally
the most important part to remember
about HTML is to make the most of its
built-in functionality native HTML
elements give you so much free stuff if
you don't want to be working on the
front end the best thing you can do is
use HTML to its maximum power because it
means that you don't have to write a
bunch of stuff so if for example you're
using a button most people I have found
will write make a div and add it on
click Handler and then they add all the
features in there
would have just given you if you just
use a button buttons and links will take
focus by default that will also can be
submitted with the enter or the spacebar
key heaps of free stuff that you get if
you try and make this on your own
typically you have to write more CSS
more JavaScript and more heat smell
together to work and nobody wants to do
that because that's boring so make the
most of what HTML provides you another
important thing to note about this is
when people make libraries like the
millions and millions that exist on NPM
most of the time they assume that you're
going to use the language appropriately
so if you don't use HTML properly and
then you try and install these libraries
often you're going to have to do more
work to get it to work so make the most
of built-in functionality make your life
easier and you get lots of free stuff so
this is the HTML we're going to use this
is what it looks like with just dibs and
this is what it looks like with proper
HTML one of these looks better than the
other just straight from the get-go it's
this one just in case so this is what
we're gonna start with just checking but
yeah this is what we're going to start
with and we're going to style it up but
before I do that I know that we all have
a ton of stuff to learn I mean at
this conference how many tracks are
there like five heaps of stuff to learn
right I'm not expecting everyone here to
remember everything all the time there
are tools for that Google's lighthouse
tool will generate reports over your
code it's not going to pick up
everything but things like performance
accessibility best practices SEO will
pick up some things for you around
misuse of HTML it has a browser
extension but there's also a
command-line tool that you can tie in
the added bonus is that you can improve
like the performance and stuff of your
website or application as you go as well
which is great because most websites
these days a on performance and
accessibility even the one that I work
on
for a moment there all right I hate
email page this is gonna be fun what
we're gonna do now is style it up and
the rest of the talk is going to be
about CSS I want to make something
really clear right now I don't give a
how you write your CSS you can use
sass stylus last for preprocessors
straight-up CSS a CSS and J's library
post CSS whatever they are
implementation details it doesn't really
matter to me how that works as far as
I'm concerned they're all the same
however I have found that when working
with back in developers and particularly
people who have worked on the back end
and write a lot of JavaScript CSS and
GIS is a lot easier for them and the
reason for that is because CSS nsj will
scope your Styles to a component and
what this does is that limits the impact
of things in CSS like the Cascade
inheritance and specificity and if you
don't know what those things are
CSS nsj might be for you however what I
would say is that CSS is very very
powerful and if you understand things
like the Cascade it will make your life
significantly easier especially if you
have to work with third parties like add
tech which really sucks or video players
I have found that in the team I work in
there is one person that can debug that
stuff and it's me the rest of the people
in the team don't really understand how
the Cascade and that kind of thing works
so they get really stuck in a bad place
so if you want to make the most of it
and use it to your advantage like it's
kind of like being given a sword but not
being able to use it properly if you
know how to use it you can just be like
fufufu and you'll do an awesome job so
that's not how you sword fight I
understand that but I'm a CSS front-end
developer not a sword fighter if anyone
is a sword fighter I come teach me that
would be awesome then I can get a real
sword and it would be cool on stage
okay anyway I'm getting sidetracked here
this is why I need to do practice runs
of my talk because I tend to get
distracted and and and ramble a bit
anyway CSS is awesome this is going to
be fun
sorry what we're going to do is start
with building the layout now we're going
to use CSS grid for this prior to CSS
grid there was many totally wack ways of
dealing with layouts on the web tables
floats it was a nightmare and we did the
best we could with the things that we
had but CSS grid was developed with
building layouts on the web in mind the
support in browsers for this is
excellent all the major browsers support
it the caveat on ie 11 is that the
syntax is slightly different but there
are ways to deal with that so it's like
I don't know if you can see this but
I've like half what I either because
it's sort of half it's kind of like I in
general really it's like half there
doesn't really matter now though because
these are the main ones we're going to
build this we have a header navigation
main content region sidebar and footer
we have we're going to start with the
columns first we've got three columns
two fixed width columns and a fluid
column in the middle and the way that we
do this with grid is we have a property
called display grid can you see that in
the back cool awesome
now that the second and the most
important part here is grid template
columns which is the property that is
going to define how we set up our
columns now because we've got three
columns we have three values the two
fixed pixel units so 200 pixels is our
navigation and 250 is our sidebar this
unit in the middle is special it was
introduced with CSS grid and it's called
a fraction unit and what it does is it
represents a fraction of the available
space in the container so in this case
whatever is left over once the 450
pixels is removed from the viewport
the next thing we have to do is make
this header span two columns the way we
do that in CSS grid is we say grid -
column start it - and span for - the
reason it's a - I'm not really sure why
but the index starts at 1 instead of 0
which for a lot of developers is a bit
confusing because normally the index
starts at 0 but I guess it made sense
when they were developing it a good way
to debug this if you've having problems
Firefox has a great grid inspector and
along the top there are numbers starting
at 1 and going to 6 and these identify
the tracks in the grid so for our code
we're saying start at 2 which is here
next to the portrait of the dude and
then we're saying span for 2 so we span
the dude and then the carpet I think
that's a carpet the read carpet thing
and that's what that Court does the
flexbox grid inspector is really really
awesome it's really great if you're
going to be working with CSS grid
because it'll tell you when you've
totally messed up and you can see where
you've made mistakes so now we've done
that we'll do our rows I'm not going to
show you what it looks like yet because
it looks a bit messy we need to do the
rows first they're actually really
similar to the columns we have two fixed
height rows and a fluid one in the
middle so the way we do this grid
template rows to fix fix pixel values
and a fluid one in the middle then what
we need to do is spend the rows with our
nav and our sidebar at this point I want
to explain something about how the flow
of HTML elements works in the browser so
the way that this actually flows in
order is header navigation main content
sidebar footer so when we move to the
header across right here is an empty
space so what we need to do is move the
nav into that empty space
whereas in this case for the sidebar
it's already where it needs to be in the
flow of the document so we don't
actually need to move it anywhere we
just need to tell it to span to rights
so the code for that would look like
this for my now grid - Road start at 1
so the top and span for 3 and with the
sidebar we can just say span for 2
because we're making the most of the way
that um the document naturally flows if
I defined a start point for this I would
also have to do it for the main content
region because otherwise it wouldn't be
in the natural flow anymore so by doing
it this way you're working with the
browser not against it and you can write
less code so this is what it looks like
I've added some color so that you can
see so I think it's okay but we need to
do something with this middle bit
because that looks messy so from the
word marshmallow down we're going to do
this man my jet lag just kicked in holy
moly ok it's alright I got this 17-hour
flight from Perth my friends direct no
stopover anyway well is that thing oh
that's right ok yeah so from boss really
down and we're gonna do this I have one
container that's gonna spend three
columns and then everything below that
is going to just line up and important
to note there are gaps between these
items so when we do our grid we say
display grid grid gap 18 pixels nice and
easy and then grid template columns
again but you'll notice this is very
different to what I just showed you
that's because this is like the best CSS
magic in the world I actually tweeted an
article about this on medium today so
you could go and read that later if you
want but there are three main parts to
this and what this will do is this will
make it work regardless of how many
columns there are so you know if you've
got a product page and you might have
six items or 127 or 40 this will work
regardless it will also be responsive
without breakpoints so it will just work
regardless of the size of the v-pool
which is what makes it super duper
amazing because breakpoints suck so
there are three main parts of this is
the repeat function it does what it
sounds like it will say for however many
items there are repeat the following
pattern then it takes true values these
values can be a whole bunch of different
things and for the purposes of today
we're going to pass in autofill and what
autofill does is it fills the row with
as many currently available items as
they are and it expands them to fill the
available space and then the last thing
is the size so instead of min max we
could just put a fixed value in or we
can use min Max and we can say I want
this content to be a minimum of two
hundred and thirty pixels and a maximum
of one fraction what this will then do
is make sure the items don't get smaller
than 230 so it doesn't get all squishy
but if they don't fit on one row and
fill the space it'll just make them
bigger to fill whatever space is left
over so it'll look like this the last
thing we need to do is make marshmallow
span three columns now you're probably
thinking what we could go one span three
but because this could be any number of
columns we can't do that because if it
was only two columns or if it was four
columns it would no longer span
correctly so instead we can say find the
first child of my group of stuff start
at one and span to the end which is what
negative one
basically means and this will mean that
it works with any number of items at any
viewport size however you need it to be
so that will give us this and just to
prove to you that it's responsive ha
magic so the problem with the original
stuff that I did with the outside is
that we need to add breakpoints in in
order to get run as a sidebar or hide
the nav as the viewport gets smaller for
mobile but with this code we don't need
to do that because it'll just work for
us so a couple of lines of CSS will give
us a flexible fluid totally responsive
web page with very little effort CSS
grid is awesome and you can use it for
all sorts of things forms cards whatever
the CSS but I presently have will also
allow me to set up a form like this that
full width I changed from using first
child to a class and then I can apply it
anywhere and then I can just use the
code that I've written to autofill to
create all of the columns as far as
resources go grid by example is free
heaps of code snippets you can just copy
and paste it's done by Rachel Andrew who
basically is the reason we have CSS grid
in the browser because she hustled all
of the browser vendors about adding it
in every layout dev is pretty much what
it says it's a resource for every layout
that you might want which is great some
of them are paid and some of them are
free but it has really good explanations
of why things work and how to use them
so I highly recommend sorry
just a little check-in this is where we
are now there is a very obvious problem
here I'm just gonna let you look at it
for a sec if you build web applications
you probably noticed it first it's this
white space at the bottom which looks
like trash we don't want that we want it
to be full height and I know some of you
if you've done stuff on the front and
you're like well that's easy we can just
go height
percent and that's true you can but the
problem with height 100% is that it
actually has to be on every single
parent item in the page and that
includes the HTML and the body element
and most people don't realize this so
they just put height 100 percent on
everything until it works and then
nobody wants to touch the CSS anymore
because they don't know if it's going to
break or not so if you understand that
that's how height work 100% works
awesome otherwise CSS implemented some
new units called viewport units so you
have the viewport height which is VH and
the viewport width which is VW and they
represent a percentage of the total
viewport height or width so for example
ten viewport width is ten percent of the
current viewport width with these units
either the container that wraps our page
you can say height 100 viewport width
and that will do it for you one line of
CSS know if a thing about with parents
it'll just work magic okay this is
looking way better so what we're going
to do now is we're going to do something
about this weirdness that's going on
here and to do that we're going to use
flexbox now often people think that we
in CSS grades you don't need flexbox but
that's actually not true
they are both useful and you can use
them together so we're going to use
flexbox to align content within our grid
flex box works in all of the major
browsers including I 11 the only caveat
I would add is technically is classed as
partial support because it's full of
bugs there is a website called flex bugs
which is on github which lists them all
and tells you how to fix them so it's
not not that difficult to get around but
in true I 11 spec it is a little bit of
a pain in the butt so we are going to
move the links up onto the same line as
the headline
using photo box but before I do that I
want to explain a couple of things about
flexbox because it always confuses
people and then they faffing about em
CSS and not really knowing what they're
doing and doing the same thing we did
with height
lots of front-end developers don't
understand this either
that's how confusing it is but I'm gonna
do my best to make it not confusing for
you so we have a div and inside the div
we have a paragraph jello is a fluffy
fellow so we have display flex and then
we're going to say a line items and
center and that is going to Center it
vertically within the div then I want
the text to be horizontally aligned so
I'm just gonna go text align Center and
that will Center the text within the
paragraph the problem with this is the
paragraph still stretches for width if I
want the paragraph to be centered then
you can use another flex box property
called justified content and justify
content center and center the whole
thing in the middle great but justified
content does a whole bunch of other
things as well so show it so I can demo
this here
I split them out into two paragraphs
jello and marshmallow respectively and
if I change justify content to Flex end
it'll move the items to the end it's
like start moves it to the start space
around it's going to evenly distribute
the space around the items and space
between will evenly distribute the items
with space between them justified
content is horizontally aligning their
items what's important to understand
about flex box is by default the Flex
Direction is a row so justify content
horizontally aligns if you change it to
a column justify content justifies it
vertically instead of horizontally so
again I've split the text up so that you
can see how this works but if I change
justify content on a column instead of a
row flex n
we'll put it at the end of the column
flex start puts it at the start spaced
around in space between will vertically
distribute the items in the dip now
you're probably thinking that's weird
why did they do that and the reason for
this is that not every language on the
web
reads left-to-right some of them read
top to bottom
some of them read right to left so when
the spec is written for CSS it has to
account for every language in the world
so it allows you to determine the main
access of the text so if it's a row it
aligns vertically and justifies
horizontally if it's a column it
justifies vertically and aligned
horizontally so for us we say display
flex justify content space between so
it'll push the link to one side in the
heading to the other and then we'll say
a line items Center and that will give
us this which is looking way better so
what we've got to do next is fix the
horrible lack of spacing and we're going
to do this with margins and padding and
that kind of thing but first I want to
talk about variables we use variables in
CSS for the same reason that we do it in
other programming languages it helps us
to reduce duplication to ensure
consistency and make maintainability a
lot easier it doesn't matter how you
write your CSS there are ways to do
variables in all versions in CSS they're
called custom properties and that's the
top row and there's a VAR function that
you can use in order to reference it
custom properties can be edited by
JavaScript which is what makes them
really cool in pre-processors they like
this one is SAS uses a dollar sign they
are compiled so they're static and you
can't change them with JavaScript and
then the bottom one is JavaScript and
obviously you can change them with
JavaScript because javascript does all
the things so with this in mind there
are a few areas that variables are
really useful for
things that define the system that I
mentioned earlier margins and padding
colors fonts that kind of thing good
design is based off systems and the best
example of this is when you set up
consistent spacing so for example these
are spacing values from the website that
I work on it's one of our news websites
for our organization and you might have
noticed that they're multiples of nine
and the reason for this is that when we
look at things visually we like patterns
and we like rhythm and multiples of a
number will give you that you could also
use the golden ratio or the Fibonacci
sequence these kinds of things help to
create a consistent rhythm in the page
and people like that you might not know
why it looks nice but you know that it
does so if you set up a consistent
spacing multiples of something whatever
use them consistently and don't just add
random values willy-nilly which a lot of
people do stick to these you'll end up
with a much nicer design so the way that
I picked what they should be I kind of
picked what I thought nice but there are
a few tips that you can follow use small
values between headings and paragraphs
so for example here you want the content
to look like it's related and not that
it's really far apart but not so close
that it runs into each other
use large values between sections like
between here this helps to separate the
content without the need for dividers
something like 18 pixels I would
consider like an anchor value because
it's used mostly throughout the whole
page and the reason for this is when you
continue to use a value it ties the page
together and ends up having a nicer feel
to it it's this kind of rhythm thing
that I was talking about and most
importantly stick to the consistent set
of values that you've defined don't just
add a bunch of new ones in
out of guessing so the next thing is
colors and fonts and when it comes to
colors I kind of already picked these
because I like purple that was pretty
much how I worked it out with the links
I went with pink because it kind of goes
with purple I'll talk about color in a
sec but when it comes to fonts there's a
few tips that you can follow draw
attention with a large font size so for
example welcome jello for things that
aren't as important use a smaller font
size so for example I made the link here
smaller because it's supplementary
information saying with timestamps not
as important as the recent activity text
but still valuable so make it a bit
smaller so that it doesn't compete with
the text around it link colors should
generally be consistent so don't put 27
different colors in for links people
tend to expect consistency in your
designs so saying with buttons have one
or two but don't go nuts with it make
sure you're using the same value
everywhere and most importantly have a
color palette and if you don't know how
to pick colors or what a color palette
is there's a heap of websites this one I
really like because it's called coolants
and you can go there and they've got a
best and picks option just go to that
because these are the ones that most
people like pick one and that's your
color palette and use those within your
design what's great about this site is
it also gives you information on the
color contrast so what it looks like
with people who have different forms of
colorblindness so you can see if people
can distinguish between colors and what
it looks like to them and so you can
make a more accessible website with that
as well okay next I want to talk about
nav specifically that thing over in the
top what is that for you left the top
left I'm not going to tell you how to
start list because we don't have time
for that but there's a couple of things
I want to specifically mention about nav
there
catches people off guard a little bit if
you've ever looked at now in CSS before
you'll notice that the links almost
always have display:block and the reason
for this is because by default links are
display:inline and an element that is
display:inline can already take up as
much space as it needs is always
displayed side by side so like in
paragraphs you can't set a width height
or top and bottom value on it for
margins and it can't contain block level
elements links are a bit of an exception
to that block level elements thing
people were constantly wrapping link
block level elements in links so they
just kind of made it work because it was
inevitable and they were like okay fine
you're gonna do that we'll make it okay
but if you wrap a link in a block level
element then you need to make the link
up display block otherwise it'll render
weird block level elements on the other
hand can take up the full width by
default they're displayed on a new line
you can set a width and a height and it
can contain other block level elements
and will all work great visually it
looks like this
so the inline one they stacked on top of
each other because they're in a list
element which is block level but the red
is the clickable area so with display
block you can see there's a much larger
clickable area than with inline which is
what we want for nav right because
people have fingers on mobile and
they're trying to click things the
larger the space the easier it is for
them as a quick aside Firefox and at the
end of last year introduced the
contextual information panel it will
tell you if you've added an opport it's
not going to do anything so in this case
if you try to add a height to an inline
element it'll be like hey that's not
gonna work have you tried this it's
really cool it's very new they keep
adding stuff but if you get stuck and
not sure why something's not working you
can always open it up in Firefox and see
if it'll give you a bit of a tip on on
how to improve it it's super awesome I
think this is one of the best features
that Firefox has added
because as a side effect it'll also tell
you what CSS you can delete from your
cone so once we've added display:block
there are two things that we want to do
first we need to change the color to
white and the reason we have to do that
is because I've already told my page
that I want all make up my links to be
pink so I have to override that secondly
we're going to add padding of 18 pixels
and the reason that we add padding and
not margin is because when you add
padding to an element it kind of adds it
to the inside
whereas margin sort of adds up to the
outside so again the red area is the
clickable area which is why padding is
what we want margin is good for putting
space between items padding is good for
making an item bigger finally the last
part is adding the interactions you
should always add a hover and a focus
style to your links and your nav and
your buttons because it tells people
that they're interacting with it I've
changed the background to pink on hover
and blue on focus and again I have to
set the color to white because I've
already got over and Phrygia States for
the rest of the links in my page so
that's gonna give us this which is great
one last thing you can do to make it
look a bit special is out of transition
property if you add transition this will
animate between the colors so in this
case I just want to animate the
background 250 milliseconds is a pretty
standard value that you can use although
you can change it to whatever you want
I wouldn't go longer than 250
milliseconds because then it will just
be painful because you'll be watching it
and you'll be going
and that will be like really annoying so
I'm just gonna use ease as the timing
and it'll look like this Oh much
prettier very nice it makes it look a
bit more finesse and a bit more
professional
don't overdo transitions and animations
because that's annoying but you can do
it on buttons links form elements when
you click into them that kind of stuff
ok so now I want to talk about images
and specifically there's one thing I
want to talk about because it's a new
feature that was added
now when you load images it kind of does
what this just did it's my dog when he
was a puppy
super cute what happens is the image
will not be there and then it'll load
and then it'll push all the content down
the page this is really bad for
performance because anything that it's
pushed needs to be redrawn by the
browser and this is bad because it ties
up the browser's processing and if you
have a news website for example like we
have and it's got hundreds of pictures
on it this really really has a negative
impact on how your site renders so the
way that we used to do resolve this
problem is we would either add a width
and a height onto the image element or a
width and a height in the CSS and this
would predefined the space and then load
the image in that and that would stop
the page from having to redraw
everything the problem with this is
because we do responsive sites these
days if you set the width to be 800
pixels and then the viewport was 400
pixels it wouldn't work anymore so then
we implemented all these weird-ass
padding hacks to determine the aspect
ratio using pseudo elements and all it
technically works it's absolutely a hack
sorry as of December last year a new
thing was implemented called it doesn't
actually have a name its intrinsic
mapping of aspect
to image elements that's the name of the
bug page and what this will do is if you
add a width and a height to the image
and then you use percentages in your CSS
the percentage will override the width
and the height but it will use the width
in the height to determine the aspect
ratio of the image and then it'll give
you the nice predetermined space and
load the image into that this is kind of
why Facebook for example has these grey
boxes everywhere and then load stuff in
there preventing the page from redrawing
the browser support for this Chrome and
Firefox both support it edge I am pretty
sure landed last night I haven't had a
chance to check but just last night it
got support and for Safari it's
currently in their preview version of
their browser so it will be supported
soon if you add this to your images on
your site or application it's going to
massively improve the performance so
I've added a jello in for fun all right
so the last thing that I want to talk
about is sticking things this is one of
my favorite things to talk about I'm
gonna tell you a little story we were
building something at my work and we
needed to stick something so one of the
devs picked it up and they wrote the
most beautiful JavaScript you have ever
seen to stick this thing in the browser
because that's how we have typically
stock things on the web before with
JavaScript a bit of CSS maybe some extra
HTML for containers but it has always
been quite buggy especially with
responsive sites because you have to
recalculate everything when it resizes
and it's never been super smooth because
you're obviously redrawing things in the
browser whenever you scroll or move
stuff around so you CSS the spec rows
were like people like to stick things
so my awesome developer wrote this
beautiful code and I was like this is
awesome but you could do this with two
lines of CSS and he was like are you
kidding me what I was like I'm really
sorry you spent all that time writing
all that beautiful JavaScript but
actually we just need position sticky
and the top offset of zero or whatever
offset you want and what that will do to
our nav which is when you scroll it'll
just stick to the top now if you change
the offset to 20 it'll be 20 pixels from
the top that kind of thing so two lines
of CSS now we'll stick something in your
page the only thing you have to remember
is that it needs a channel to move
through so whatever the size of the
parent container will determine how much
it sticks so if the sidebar was the same
height as the nav it wouldn't move
anywhere because there's nowhere for it
to move to so you just have to remember
that the parent container determines how
long it sticks for and make sure there's
enough room for it to move the browser
support for this is Chrome Firefox
Safari edge not ie if you're worried
about IE I'm gonna tell you right now
don't be worried about it I have never
come across a situation where sticky was
critical functionality most of the time
it's used to stick ads and nobody gives
a about that so just don't support
it in IE 11 the browser will just ignore
the CSS so you can just put it in and
leave it sorry
we started off here with our beautiful
proper structured HTML and we ended up
here I added in a dog logo at the top
it's an SVG I couldn't help myself it's
very cute
but we basically went through and added
in all of the things that we needed one
step at a time to create our final page
it ended up being 174 lines of CSS I
said we'd do it in under 200 and when I
picked that value it was a guess and
then I was pretty happy when it came out
174 there are a few extra things in
qinger that I didn't mention because I
didn't have time to go through it all
like the lists and that kind of thing
some extra stuff to make it responsive
but with this CSS you can create a bunch
of different layouts I really just
wanted an excuse to show you more
pictures of my dog this one I
particularly like because he's a cool a
big brain anyway you can do a bunch of
different stuff with the same kind of
CSS you might find that you don't have
to add anything else or you just have to
add a little bit of extra CSS in order
to get it to work so instead of loading
in thousands of lines of bootstrap you
could just write a few simple little
things to get you most of the way there
and it is something you can absolutely
do starting with a really strong
foundation and then building upon it
will make it easier to maintain the
biggest problem that I found developers
have with CSS isn't CSS itself it's the
way that it's been implemented because
if you've got a huge codebase regardless
of what the technology is it's hard to
maintain and the more you add on to it
without taking stuff away the harder it
gets to maintain so if you can keep it
as small as possible it's going to be
much easier for you to work with so on
that note thanks very much here a bunch
of resources highly recommend mdn it
literally gives you everything that you
need CSS tricks is also awesome for
flexbox and grid and if you have any
questions if there's anything you
specifically have a requirement for that
you don't know how to do please feel
free to tweet me or as I said I'll be
around I mean you can come and talk to
me about it as well the front end it
might not be something that you work on
all the time but it's something you can
absolutely do and you might start
to enjoy it after a while if you give it
a bit of a well there's lots of fun
things you can do on the front end so
you should get involved and have a go
and have some fun with it thanks
[Applause]